hello everyone and welcome at our
presentations on visions
an open source library for semantic data
my name is simon bruchmann
and i'm presenting it with ian eaves
um so let's start off with defining some
terms
so we're talking about data types and
one way to view data types is as being
defined by a set of possible values
and intuitively we can understand
uh semantic types as something we're
working with every day so
if you think about names or countries
there are abstracts
abstracts meanings of sequences of data
a probability as well but when we're
moving into the
realm of computation these have to
become real types that the computer can
reason with and that's
a machine representation which you're
probably familiar with
for example the way that a database
represents
represents the data our pandas does an
integer or a float or
a varchar type
and in the next slide we will see how
these relate so these types are not
exclusive
for example if you have normally
distributed numbers the database of the
machine will represent it as a float for
the binomials as an integer
words starting with an s can be
represented as strings
and the answer to live the universe and
everything can be stored in an integer
so these are not exclusive they are not
in
conflict they may work together we
invest a lot of effort and time about
optimizing and thinking about how
to use this machine representation but
the semantic representation
will actually help us make better
programs
so why do semantics matter now for
example this
this case this headline you might have
seen it where scientists had to actually
rename human genes
uh to prevent excel from misreading them
as dates so these were march one
and september one and um
this is not incidental the past year
alone 27 genes had to be changed
like this in by the
human gene nomenclature committee yes
next slide so why is this
important so first the semantic types as
i already mentioned
drive application logic if you're
writing applications that are data
intensive you will need it
however in the python environment
there's no out-of-the-box solution for
this
and if you don't use the right
abstraction then it's becoming a mess
real quick it's really
easy to write convoluted code where
would you need it
you would need this anywhere that you
use abstract typing on a sequence of
data so this can be data cleaning
automl data profiling data compression
and many more examples
and what we are talking about is visions
which is a framework
that allows you to model the data the
semantic data types
and do type detection
so this example is an example in pandas
where you have a sequence of integers
one two three and four
however once you add one single string
so
four as a string then the memory usage
will increase because it's automatically
coerced to an object
and what we're talking about is the the
kind of logic
to prevent and solve these cases because
this is what you would encounter in
real life so the next
slide will and so this is um
a way that typically everyone solves
this by as a sequence of
checks and these sequence of checks
are in pandas in dusks and
[Music]
yeah there's an order dependency here
it and it doesn't scale and these are
the things that you will run
into when you're defining this logic
another reason why we're doing it is uh
because we've noticed but also others
have noticed the importance of this some
semantic detection for example those
bills that all say
the detection of semantic types is
crucial for data science tasks such as
automatic data cleaning
and they're shared by many so this is
from mit but there's also microsoft
the umass and wes mckinney also
mentioned this in a
documentation of need for panas 2.0
well what's available currently we've
seen before you can use
apply this ad hole logic but we are more
interested in automating this or
making it more efficient there's of
course the built-in inference in
open source tools but it's it doesn't
allow to
customize and we've seen also before
that it's tricky when you have for
example one
string item and we've also looked at
commercial
software for example power bi tableau
and trifacta they they have a limited
support for
a custom type no support for custom type
but limited support for semantic types
which are for example in tableau
dependent on the
and the headers and not on the values
in terms of where you would apply this
um you can think of pandas profiling
for exploratory data analysis we're
actually using it
for great expectation which is a library
to generate data validation
rules called expectations you could map
the semantic types automatically to
to these rules similarly for pokemon
which does
validation over time uh model monitoring
data monitoring
we've also used it in compressio to
make efficient compression of your
pandas data frames
you can also use it for data clean in
many more other applications
moving to what what is vision visions is
a
package we've built which aims to make
logic explicit and expressive
to allow the user to make composable
composable
modeling of their problem in a graphical
structure
um the user has to be able to write
performance code
and we support type inference detection
and casting out of the box with a simple
api
and now i'm handing over to ian who will
introduce the
concepts and vision thanks
[Music]
so in order to make visions work we
really need to understand
three basic concepts the first
types this is this corresponds to
everything simon was just discussing
these these are semantic or logical
abstract
understandings of the values and meaning
of our data
now when we're actually implementing
this
visions requires two fundamental
elements the first a class
which inherits from visions based type
right
coming along with with that inheritance
is a variety of
um default capabilities out of you know
support for set type operations um
a whole host of other capabilities but
truly what's required is a contains
operation so
this is a function which takes as its
input a sequence
and evaluates whether that sequence is
of the abstract type
defining it so in the generic case
generic
is kind of a universal set it is the the
type
that all sequences belong to so if we
say
the sequence hello world sequence is
that a member
of generic s and generic that evaluates
to true
types can kind of be visualized in this
sort of um
set-based perspective and
probably this set-based perspective is
something most of you are already
familiar with
so within the context of generic kind of
a universal set
we have numeric values which themselves
break down into continuous and discrete
might have the sequence one two and
three as an instance of a discrete value
where
um the the sequence 1.1
2.2 3.3 might be continuous
difference between interval versus um
not similarly we have categories
and these break down maybe into um those
that are ordered
so ordinal or those that are not ordered
so nominal
um that would be like cat dog cat right
there's no inherent
order to cats and dogs
now it's not enough to only talk about
types though
right what's interesting is how these
types relate to each other
you know we saw a number of examples
earlier where one type
we had a type of data where maybe it was
a string
encoding an integer but we weren't so
much interested in it as a string we
wanted to do something with its numeric
um in that case we add one new method
so here we we have an implementation of
string that you you might see in vision
something
similar to this um our contains op is
only slightly changed now we're checking
whether each value is itself a string
um but we've added a new a new method
that's this get relations method and
that's going to return a list
of relations now critically within
visions
the the mechanism of relating types is a
little bit different than
is usually intuitive and found in most
applications so
most people think you know if i have a
sequence of strings one two three
uh i might try to coerce that to other
things so i might make that i might try
making that
first a float or i might first try
making that an integer or so on i'm
gonna go through a list of options
um so that's mapping from the type
of the sequence to another type visions
does the reverse
so it asks the question um how can i map
a to myself so if i'm a string what can
i
what can i convert to me um that might
be
you know generic becoming string that
might be
um you know an integer
coming from a string so
that also it kind of inherently produces
two possibilities
we might either do that without
transforming the underlying data
in the case of generic becoming string
or we might have to change the
underlying data
in case of string becoming integer
that difference is the difference
between what visions calls an identity
relation and an inference relation
so identity relations no change to the
data no transformation
infants relations do require a change
so here we we have the example of an
integer and we have a relationship
between
integer and string that requires
a conditional mapping so first there's a
test
whether that transformation is
applicable we might attempt the coercion
if it succeeds then we would say it is
and second a transformation which
actually modifies the
the underlying data
going back to our our set view you know
this would be akin to saying
or observing i have the sequence one two
three encoded a string
and i see intuitively and looking at
this
that i can apply integer to that
sequence
and get the discrete numeric value uh
1 2 3 as integers first i would attempt
the coercion
that is the conditional element and then
i would actually perform the coercion
creating a conditional mapping or
inference relation
the third and final piece is the typeset
and this is really just building up all
of the pieces we've
we've already established so a typeset
is at its most primitive
a directed asymptotic graph right so it
is this
the relationship between a set of types
because we've defined relationships in
the way that we have
they have become composable we can add
them together and in fact vision
supports exactly that sort of
api you can add subtract types from a
typeset at will
and it will reconfigure the graph on the
backend on the fly
so um with all of those pieces
we get three new fundamental
capabilities
um typeset type detection and type
inference
these are the two sides of the relation
coin so the identity relation and the
inference relation
type detection is determining the type
of a sequence
absent any transformation so not no
changes to the underlying data if i give
you the
the sequence one two three is encoded as
strings then i would expect that to be
returned a type of string on the other
hand
inference permits uh transformation
throughout the graph so in that case we
should say you know if i infer the type
i i would get a more specific
representation which is
one two three as integers
casting is is basically the same as
inference except
rather than returning the type i'm
getting the actual
uh the actual values of the sequence of
the the core sequence
and all of these correspond to traversal
around
or along a graph along the graph that
corresponds to our typeset
so this is a really uh simple
visualization hopefully of
the complete set within visions you can
import that
right now and let's just do a quick
example so so we get the
the series uh consists of a sequence of
dates encoded as
uh strings uh and a missing value
indicator none
uh by default it's already generic we
can tell that because
generic is the universal set right it's
the type that everything else belongs to
um and what we're going to do is just
try each type
each child node that is of the current
type of the sequence so we know it's
generic
uh we'll try categorical boolean complex
whatever it's related to
now that does correspond to
to one observation it's important to
keep in mind
in order for the traversal of this graph
to be deterministic
the relationships between child nodes
in the graph have to be disjoint so i
can't have a sequence that's both
boolean and complex at the same time
this is not required for visions to work
but it is required to have a
deterministic traversal
all right so let's just do this quickly
um
first we might try something like
categorical we'd see that the the
sequence s
it's encoded as a pandas object
so it's not going to correspond to the
pandas category these are two different
uh physical implementations of the same
data
so this would be false it's not a
categorical
okay so we have to try another type i'm
going to try object next and we'll see
that
ah yes so because our sequence is string
pandas encodes that as an object if we
check for it to be an object
that will be true we can now traverse to
the next layer of the graph
and determine that our d type is at
least object
we'll attempt one more layer down one
more child
[Music]
and see string intuitively again our
sequence is currently encoded as a
string so that will be true
we can traverse again and now we hit
another
uh kind of bifurcation you might have
noticed already that there are two types
of lines on this graph
solid and dashed solid corresponds
to identity relations again no
transformation for the underlying data
dashed corresponds to inference
relations transformations to the
underlying data
every child node of string is an
inference relation
so that means we're gonna have to do
something a little bit different here
but let's let's proceed and we'll hit it
in a second
okay first maybe we try complex
we see that it's not complex we try
coursing the the value 1937-5-6
doesn't that fails so it's not complex
we'll try daytime next and we'll see
that ah yes
we can coerce all those values to
daytime objects that's true
now we have to perform a transformation
though so before we can say that our
because our date time object is defined
assuming
actual date times under the hood we have
to transform our string
into its representation um presumed by
the type
so that involves an additional
transformation step here
we transform the sequence of
date time encoded strings to the
sequence of date times
with a panda's missing value missing
time indicator
in a t there's one child left
we basically perform the same process we
see that
date is effectively a date time where
the time values are zero
and that is the case in our example um
so we'll transform again and we'll end
up with our final type of date
and our final series of dates um
with say in the first value the year
1937
the month five and the day six
that'll hand it back to simon yes thank
you ian
now that we have the core concepts and
we know how the graph reversal works
we can go to a real example so in the
in this slide you see the adhoc logic
for
machine learning task classification
meaning that given a target
sequence the label we want to infer
which kind of problem it is
in terms of machine learning so it can
be multi-class problem it can be a
binary classification problem or a
regression problem
and what you see from this example from
real life it's it's quite convoluted can
be
can be quite convoluted in the next
slide we see the
visions equivalent of this code so what
we
do we do in vision divisions is make two
type sets the variable type
set here denoting the statistical set
we've seen before but
with the addition of a binary type for
binary classification
and define the other type as being a
typeset as being the problem set
and it's quite easy to map logic from
the variable side set to the problem set
to actually solve for problem
so on the left we see the code one of
the benefits here is that it's easy to
reason about and to test but in the in
this slide we in the next slide we also
see that it's easy to extend
so in this case we added a poisson
regression type a negative
binomial regression and ordinal
regression
and you can see in the problem set on
the bottom right that it's
easily visualized and adding the type
also
has a clear place where you would add
this logic well in the original site it
was
difficult so this is a
this is the example and now we proceed
with
and the batteries included thanks so
much
yes much like python visions comes
batteries included
and what that means is we offer default
support for a wide variety of libraries
and data structures
these are some of the most common tools
used throughout the data science
ecosystem
currently we support python and pandas
default data structures out of the
box actually numpy included in that we
have
active development to bring in support
for for spark
and digs das excuse me um
with fix and uh alchemy on the way
we facilitate support for these native
library or these libraries natively
using a dispatch based system some of
you may be familiar with this already
um others may be familiar with it and
under the name
kind of overloading from the sea
landscape
but the basic idea here is we can modify
which method is invoked as traversal
occurs throughout the data
throughout the typeset based on the
type of data that's provided in its
arguments so we can write a a
custom git operation or contains
operation
for numpy or panda series
or tuples all of which are able to
then leverage the specific capabilities
of that object
um you know this might mean the the
implicit
numped type of pandas ornamenty um
or the parallelization afforded by desk
or spark
but visions comes with an expansive and
constantly growing suite of types and
typesets that should cover most of the
most common use cases in
in practice obviously that means the
physical types
integers floats strings
so on but even the less common ones
urls files paths
images date times shapely geometries
all are available out of the box and are
constantly being expanded
we offer a wide range of diagnostic and
testing tools for
users as they want to
contribute or develop their own types
you know one of the inherent
challenges with this is is building
something that's robust to all the
various types of
of inputs they can receive and we found
having uh kind of a
a toolbox of of test data to be
extraordinarily useful in that
endeavor we also offer a functional and
object-oriented api
uh and built-in plotting capabilities oh
this is
invaluable when it comes to diagnostics
looking forwards um we plan to
incorporate spark and desk
out of the box support and the coming
future
obviously we're always continuing to
expand our type library
and default type sets all of which are
available the simple import from the
package
and we'll be looking to further
integrate into a number of applications
if you're interested you can find out
more on github so
dylan profiler backslash visions
everything is
you know accessible on pip so you can
get started tomorrow
um but if you're interested in
contributing
um or adding an application or seeing if
this could work for your application
please feel free to reach out to us or
make a pull request both are always
extremely welcome
if you're interested in seeing some of
the applications it's already integrated
in you can check out
compressio at dillon profiler backslash
compressio
our memory management and
data compression tool for pandas or
pandas profiling
one of the highly lauded eda tools for
pandas
thanks so much